Вони протестують проти кривавої бійні, яку почала Росія.
Українські діти, жінки, літні люди,
котрі втекли від війни на південь Франції.
Їм допомагає волонтерка Ірина Бурдель. Українка давно живе тут.
"Війна триває. Зима буде дуже і дуже складною.
Для нас тут теж, але в Україні це набагато, набагато складніше.
Ось чому люди досі прибувають сюди".
"Путін терорист!"
Оксана Басова - теж волонтерка.
Вихователька дитячого садка виїхала з Києва
після російського вторгнення.
Її чоловік - інженер - продовжує там працювати.
Він відновлює системи електропостачання,
зруйновані російськими ракетами.
Син Оксани, Олексій, знає:
російські бомби загрожують життю його батька,
а мати бореться за виживання тут.
Але на Лазуровому березі є й інші біженці з України.
Вони живуть на розкішному курорті Сен-Жан-Кап-Ферра
неподалік від Ніцци.
Вони полюбляють демонструвати своє багатство:
мільйонери, мільярдери - олігархи.
Багатьох із них вважають давніми агентами впливу Путіна в Україні.
І одними з головних корупціонерів.
Нині вони постійні гості в казино Монте-Карло.
Влітку незалежне українське інтернет-видання
"Українська правда" опублікувало їхні імена.
Тих, кого жартома називають "Батальйон Монако".
Деякі з них були депутатами Верховної Ради від проросійських партій, які тепер заборонені в Україні.
"Ці люди були не лише частиною корумпованої еліти,
вони несуть відповідальність за війну в Україні, тому що
закликали Росію прийти в Україну.
Тому ми вважаємо, що вони несуть повну відповідальність за цю катастрофу".
Із українськими мільярдерами у волонтерок Ірини та Оксани
немає контактів.
Місто Ніцца безкоштовно надало цю крамницю
Французько-українській культурній асоціації.
Нині тут допомагають біженцям - українським дітям,
які отримали психологічні травми.
Поруч приймають приватні пожертви.
Більша частина приміщення потрібна асоціації
для догляду за дітьми і вивчення з ними французької мови.
На вулиці нужденні матері та бабусі
стоять у черзі по безкоштовну їжу.
Раз на тиждень сюди можуть прийти всі охочі, щоби стати на облік.
Приватні пожертви та харчування
фінансує управління соціального забезпечення Ніцци.
Кілька банок сардин.
Але чи вистачить цього на цілий тиждень?
"Ні, ні".
Тим часом надійшли нові пожертви:
одяг, дитяче харчування, предмети гігієни.
Усе це зібрали працівники великої ІТ-компанії.
Людовік Убле організував цю акцію.
Він керує двома місцевими організаціями, які підтримують українців.
"Ми намагаємося допомогти, бо люди, на жаль, страждають.
Тут потрібна наша участь як громадянського суспільства".
Людовік Убле також керує місцевим клубом ораторського мистецтва.
Це неабиякий клуб: він розташований
на "острові мільйонерів" Кап-Феррат.
Однак жоден із українських багатіїв не долучився до пожертв.
"Гадаю, кожен має відігравати свою роль.
Ми відіграємо свою роль. Чи роблять це вони? Я не знаю".
Обідній час. Син Оксани Басової, Олексій, повертається зі школи.
Вони з матір'ю орендують маленьку мансарду.
Оксана Басова заробляє трохи грошей,
викладаючи французьку мову для українських біженців.
Це маленький новий початок, аби вижити.
"Я втратила роботу, мій маленький бізнес в Україні, в Києві.
Я мала чоловіка, була самостійною
та керувала приватним дитячим садком.
Я доглядала кілька десятків дітей, а потім
почалася війна і я мусила зачинити садок".
Тим часом біженці-мільйонери катаються на яхтах і лімузинах.
У березні український антикорупційний блогер опублікував фото.
Це приблизно 28 мільйонів доларів США
і майже півтора мільйона євро.
Знімок зробила угорська митниця під час в'їзду до ЄС
дружини одного українського депутата.
Як митниця на південному заході України могла не помітити контрабанду готівки, можна лише здогадуватися.
Але не виключено, що на кону в української колонії
біженців класу люкс - не лише гроші.
Вранішня пробіжка по Кап-Ферра Ігоря Абрамовича -
депутата Верховної Ради від уже забороненої ОПЗЖ.
Він покинув лави прихильної до Росії партії ще до заборони.
У травні цього року разом зі своїми поплічниками
він засновує нову депутатську групу: "Відновлення України".
Що це - відновлення старих проросійських альянсів?
У сонячному вигнанні?
Депутат відмовляється коментувати це українським ЗМІ.
У  Києві зараз - мінусові температури.
Там уважно стежать за новими мережами старих друзів Москви.
Активіст-антикорупціонер Олександр Саліженко
спеціалізується на депутатах українського парламенту
і їхніх контактах.
"За даними "Української правди", це Сергій В'язьмікін,
колишній начальник Департаменту захисту економіки Нацполіції - разом із Ігорем Абрамовичем".
Київські слідчі спрямували в європейські поліцейські організації
запити на розшук двох із кількох десятків підозрюваних.
Ми зв'язалися із прес-секретарем Державного бюро розслідувань.
"Нині перевіряється, чи законно громадяни, про яких іде мова в журналістському розслідуванні,
перетнули кордон, і чи причетні вони
до легалізації майна, яке отримали,
як підозрюють слідчі Державного бюро розслідувань,
швидше за все, злочинним шляхом".
"Ґрунтуючись на попередньому досвіді,
перспективи цієї справи і екстрадиції невеликі".
Але цього недостатньо для українських жінок у центрі для біженців.
"Після війни рано чи пізно в цих людей запитають,
чим вони займалися, і їм доведеться відповідати за свої вчинки".
Вони сподіваються, що українські друзі Кремля потраплять за ґрати.
А також на те, що ймовірній мережі на Кап-Ферра -
так званому "батальйону Монако" - настане кінець.